have you ever seen prince as a child
he's like a mythical creature i mean
very few images exist
um that is until a stroke of luck led
our minneapolis station wcco to unearth
an incredible gym wcco anchor jeff
wagner joins us right now jeff what did
you find
well it all started with our production
manager matt liddy who went digging deep
into these film archives for footage of
the 1970 minneapolis teacher strike it
was for a story we were working on and
he stumbled upon some video in that film
you're just gonna have to see it to
believe
[Music]
on a film reel of a teacher strike more
than 50 years ago an interview with one
student immediately stood out are most
of the kids in favor of the picketing
yes
how come
i think they get a better education too
cuz
and i think they should get some more
money because they're going to be
working extra hours for us and all that
stuff
the first thing i thought was i can't
believe that's him wcco production
manager matt liddy made the discovery i
immediately just went out to the
newsroom and started showing people and
saying
i'm not going to tell you who i think
this is but who do you think this is and
every single person
prince yes that prince prince rogers
nelson the minneapolis born and bred
global superstar but there was one catch
we did not get him saying i'm prince
nelson so we set out to get some
confirmation there's not a ton of images
of prince as a kid we asked historian
kristen schommler who's extensively
researched and written about the purple
one to take a look at the footage and
well
i think that's him definitely
oh my gosh
and this definitely looks like
lincoln junior high school where he
would have been attending school in
april of 1970. we also compared it to a
photo of prince when he was believed to
be in the sixth grade despite the
evidence we still needed someone who
knew prince as a kid to confirm we go
back as far as kindergarten and john
hale elementary in north minneapolis
that someone was terence jackson a
childhood friend and neighbor who played
in prince's first band grand central
when they were teenagers that is friends
standing right through the headline
right yeah keep watching keep watching
that skipper
oh my gosh
that's him wow that was him
what do you
i'm like blown away and flabber totally
i'm totally blown away mark my words you
guys have found a real gem
as far as we can tell this video is the
oldest video of prince that we can find
in the public outside of maybe his
personal archive and i think our
production manager matt liddy put it
best i don't know why this is cool but
it is but it is
jeff that is a great find and a great
story of finding out that yes that is
indeed prince did his childhood friend
say hey that's skipper is that a new
nickname we got there
so that's like a family nickname it's
it's funny because earlier in the story
when we talked with the historian she
was showing us a picture of him as a
toddler and it was labeled as skipper
they used to call him skipper she
mentioned to me so to hear him revert
back to that nickname immediately just
shows you that he wasn't prince the
superstar that was his neighborhood
friend skipper
very cool big shout out to matt liddy
yeah good find matt lydia yes little
princess on the right side of the
teacher strike as well give them more
pay more support yes you know the
children are our future jim wagner thank
you very much wcco we appreciate it